For the final project in this course,
you're going to build databased backed
software to run a particular kind
of game or sporting tournament.
In a Swiss style game tournament,
players aren't eliminated when they
lose a match, every player,
gets to play in every round.
And in each round,
each player plays against someone with
about the same number of wins and losses
that they have, which means that each
player is likely to be matched against
an opponent with about equal strength.
Ties are broken by looking at how well
the tied players' opponents have done.
After all beating two
strong opponents counts for
more than beating two weak opponents.
This system was invented in Zurich,
Switzerland in 1895 for chess.
But it is now used for a wide variety
of games and sports around the world.
And keeping track of such a complicated
tournament is a good job for a database.
In this lesson,
you'll be writing a python module
that uses the PSQL database,
to pair up players in each round of
a tournament and record their results.